[Musique]
croyez vous qu'il y ait deux papas plus
jeune neuf autres aux échos notez bien
sur vos trois mois dans votre attention
il nous manque un
[Musique]
comme tu es d'âge mon patin ce soit
robin et pour te faire plaisir il y aura
un grand plat de pâtes partage staff
qu'est ce que tu as dit aujourd'hui papa
chouette alors que le million
[Musique]
actions terminent ce qu'il ya pour la
vie ne au nom aussi des clous pathé sud
je n'ai pas possible vous savez ce que
j'ai vu sur la table de la cuisine
un paquet de pâtes c'est la huitième
fois que mon mangeant des pâtes cette
semaine c'est épouvantable ça fait
grossir bon aux grands maux les grands
remèdes qui m'arrive de nata truc de
pata truc j'ai trouvé le truc
venez pour garder le charme de votre
silhouette
fait manger des pâtes à l'eau
oublier nos dix morts
de la vie
oubliée la gym
pata pata lourd pour paris
la tablette
[Musique]
manger des pâtes à l'eau
la sambre curieux n'y a rien qui cuit
ça sent bon quand même je ne quitte pas
tant que ça qu'est ce qui t'arrive
portée pour nous un patin coeur aussi à
la maison on regrette toi tu es trop
faible heureusement qu'il ya des pâtes
pour le dîner trafford défi au sac à
papier aux chercheurs d'assassiner pièce
qui me bombarde avec des pâtes
alimentaires de second choix
alors j'ai fait mon paquet de pâtes
comment at il pu sauter par la fenêtre
sans le vent on se voit beaucoup de 20g
jaillir éborgné excusez-nous monsieur
bougon ce n'est pas notre faute on
décharge
nous vous invitons à dîner pour vous
faire oublier ce petit malheur lève pas
les pattes à peluches je viendrai je
vous ferai un gros plat de pâtes attend
ce pas monsieur bougon ni vers 8 heures
mais ces bouffons dites moi la vérité
vous n'aimez pas les pattes
j'en ai horreur mais comment refuser le
gentil habitation vous en faites pas
nous allons tout arranger vous et moi
votre cas monsieur bougon elle est en
place les parts sont signalés sur la
droite
et voilà le plat préféré des temples des
hauts murs embauches au cours la même
robe au chocolat c'était une surprise
pour monsieur bougon je voulais lui
montrer les merengues avant le dîner des
ne soyez pas trop triste il reste un
grand plat de pâtes